[Applause]
supermarket worker Yesenia and her two
young children Jorge and Jasmine are
fleeing they say for their lives across
the sukiyaki River from Guatemala to
Mexico they tried first across the
border bridge with a caravan and
thousands of Central Americans trying to
reach the US Yesenia told us why thanks
just come to extort you and you have to
pay all there's a gun to your head they
asked me for half my salary of the $20
zone a day I'd have to give them ten and
I have to provide for my children there
wasn't enough left Mexican authorities
weren't prepared to let the caravan go
through the bridge crossing together
only in small groups the migrants feared
that would just lead to deportation so a
mass exodus began to the water
everyone's now decided that crossing the
bridge of trying to cross it isn't worth
it so they're crossing the river that's
right next to it with the helping hand
they made it
what good did it do closing the gates if
we were going to cross anyway which she
spoke too soon Mexico's security forces
were waiting chaos broke out
Yesenia dropped the rocks out with
everything they had and they scrambled
up the banks at the top a race between
the National Guard and migrants to
outflank each other many people got
through or resisted attempts to detain
them we saw the National Guard push
people back but refrain from using
excessive force but some tear gas did
get into Jorge's eyes it was too much
for him and Yesenia we're going back but
we'll try and go again we have to cross
whatever happens I need a better life
for my children but just as they were
heading back to the river and migration
agent arrived with food water
I need asylum there are too many
criminals in Guatemala Yesenia and her
family were taken to a health clinic and
then let go but many were less lucky and
hundreds ended the afternoon on the
Mexican bank of the sukiyaki River John
Holman al-jazeera Ciudad de al gore